je regrette que il n'y ait rien sur les
peines planchées qui devraient protéger
l'uniforme de la République et je le dis
c'est peine plancher aurait été bien
utile face aux extrémistes de scène
solide et qui ont provoqué des violences
extrêmement graves et vous avez eu
raison de parler des côtes terrorisme
c'est peine plancher c'est peine
plancher aurait été nécessaire face à
ces hors de sauvages qui ont attaqué les
gendarmes vous n'avez pas hésiter à
assimiler sans distinction tous les
écologistes à des terroristes
n'assimilation dangereuse vous le savez
je suis certaine monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur que vous le savez que le
terrorisme ce n'est pas ce que nous
incarnons ici et j'en veux pour preuve
du risque qu'il y a les Outrans que mon
collègue fiotit vient de commettre à
l'instant à notre rencontre n'est pas
normal que ces propos là puissent avoir
lieu au sein de nous
institutions alors que les élus de la
République des représentants du peuple
se sont effectivement fait molestés par
des forces de l'ordre sur ordre et dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions vous
n'avez pas eu ni mes collègues ni vous
monsieur le ministre un seul mot pour
nos collègues
Lisa bellucco et Benoît Biteau
mais parce qu'il y a un objectif
important à renforcer notre sécurité à
porter la réorganisation de notre vie
c'est de la gendarmerie de l'être et là
mais questionnements et je vous invite
et je nous invite à ne pas nous perdre
dans les investis personnels et avancer
sur le fond je mise donc sur vos propos
et la volonté de dialogue affiché que
monsieur le rapporteur et monsieur le
Président vous saurez mettre en œuvre il
serait dommage quand même que nous nous
braquions collectivement au moment où de
gros textes important pour la France
profil et les 49-3 commencent à se
raréfier je reviendrai pas sur l'épisode
de ce weekend je constate que vous avez
pas un mot sur les 66 gendarmes qui ont
été blessés dans quelques-uns on la
mâchoire écrasé peut-être qu'ils ne
pourront plus parler de leur vie donc
dans l'entendre dans les communiqués de
presse que les créations publiques
je vraiment je regrette qu'au départ un
mot d'équilibre pour pour ces pères et
mère de famille qui ont subi une extrême
violence une extrême violence et je
crois que les images les images qu'on
les Français ont vu on constaté d'une
part l'extrême violence qu'on subit les
gendarmes pour une manifestation qui
était interdite et validée comme cette
interdiction par le juge je réessayais
de rappeler et deuxièmement chacun a vu
les provocations
de certains élus et ça a été vu par la
France entière je crois et que je crois
que c'est des excuses qu'il fallait
présenter et pas des insultes aux
policiers et je vais vous dire je
mais monsieur bernalicis monsieur
bernalicis un député c'est pas une
immunité vivante et de respecter toutes
les règles de la République Monsieur
monsieur maresis qu'on veut te respecter
il faut être respectable il doit
respecter toutes les règles de la
République
toutes les règles de la République
Monsieur bernalicis monsieur Bernal ici
toutes tes règles de la République enfin
vous avez chacun pu prononcer des mots
qui sont des mots fermes qui sont des
mots qui vous engagent dans le plus
grand des silence et des calmes que j'ai
maintenu donc si vous pouvez faire
autant lors de la réponse du ministre je
vous en remercierai non mais s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît le ministre il a
souffert de vos autres observations de
vos commentaires qu'ils partagent
probablement pas toutes d'accord voilà
donc maintenant vous le laissez répondre
et il trouve que le ministre est par
ailleurs lui aussi parlementaire donc il
ne dévalue pas le travail des
parlementaire mais je pense que tous les
députés et tous les sénateurs ne sont
pas au dessus des lois de la République
et alors les députés de laupestre ne
sont pas au dessus des lois de tous les
autres députés non plus voilà donc je
pense qu'il faut respecter les règles de
la République il n'y a pas les règles
des uns et les règles des autres il y a
la loi de la République cette
manifestation était interdite je ne vous
ferai pas je ne vous ferai pas
l'historique de cette infrastructure
agricole qui j'appelle a été validé par
des gouvernements qui ne sont pas les
nôtres avec les députés qui se disaient
écologiste qui était ministre à l'époque
on est des autorisations et je ne vous
validerai pas le fait que par ailleurs
le juge qui parfois nous interdit
d'interdire de manifestations de les a
validés et je veux vous dire ici que je
suis con je suis fier de la façon dont
les gendarmes se sont comportés tout le
monde a vu qu'ils ont subi des
provocations des attaques à coup de
pierre à coups de cocktail Motors à coup
de pieux et ça n'a rien à voir avec des
manifestations qui relèvent de Gandhi
vous n'êtes pas Gandhi vous étiez
manifestement du côté de jeux de ceux
qui ont attaqué de ce qu'on va attaquer
les gendarmes à coups de pierre de 15 cm
et qui ont des mâchoires et des
mâchoires écrasées je veux vous dire ici
je veux vous dire ici qu'il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de pouvoir
extraordinaire au-delà de la loi des
parlementaires et je pense que la
grandeur du parlementaire c'est
justement de respecter les lois qui sont
votées par le peuple souverain et vous
malheureusement je constate que
indépendamment de celui-ci est des
manifestations violentes que nous avons
vu du comportement je crois inacceptable
c'est mon jugement personnel d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont en
effet élus et que tout le monde a pu
constater qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
provocation de la part des gendarmes et
que c'était bien averse qui avait été
fait je veux redire ici je regrette
profondément profondément que vous
n'avez pas un mot pour ces pères Emma de
famille qui ont fait leur travail de
fonctionnaire et d'ailleurs je veux vous
dire que dans toutes vos interventions
j'entends beaucoup de critiques sur la
police et gendarmerie j'ai pas encore
entendu un soutien ce qui montre sans
doute un inconscient qui est tout à fait
qui est tout à fait conscient donc je ne
rentrerai pas dans cette
ultime provocation je crois que vous
auriez été grandi de reconnaître que ce
week-end n'était pas très flatteur et
l'écologie et sans doute renoble pour
être prise en effet par l'hyper violence